i believe that a large-scale
resettlement of the world population is
increasingly necessary to compensate for
the dangerous misalignment
in our foundational
geographies
there are four layers of geography that
underpin human civilization
and today
they are badly out of sync
the first
is natural geography
this is the geography and location and
distribution of our resources
on maps such as this
brown represents the deserts
blue represents the oceans green
represents the forest and so forth but
this layer of geography
is very much in flux due to the
acceleration of climate change
industrial agriculture and deforestation
are reducing the volume and the expanse
of the green
drought and desertification are
expanding the brown
greenhouse gas emissions are turning our
air black
drying up our rivers and polluting our
oceans
as temperatures rise our glaciers melt
future maps will have less white over
the andes the rockies the alps the
himalayas and of course the polar ice
caps as well and as sea levels rise
they encroach upon and inundate
our coastlines so future maps will
therefore also have more blue
the second layer is the political
geography of states and borders
this is the most arbitrary of our
cartographic lenses
in 1945 the united nations had only 51
members
today it has nearly 200 members
that's the result of post-world war ii
decolonization after which more than 100
new countries were born and of course
the collapse of the soviet union 30
years ago there have never been as many
sovereign states in fact as we have
today
the third layer of geography is the
functional
infrastructure that we have built
these are the intentional investments
that we have been making to connect us
to each other
these lines represent the highways and
the railways the electricity grids and
the oil and gas pipelines the seaports
and airports the fiber optic internet
cables that have blanketed much of the
world
all of our supply chains much of the
global economy and quite frankly our
civilization as we know it
has come to depend on this connectivity
and here's the map that you see least of
all this is the map of us
this is our human geography it's our
distribution across the planet
every one of us eight billion pixels
and of course
where we are
is no accident
after millennia of nomadism
the retreat of the ice age
more than 10 000 years ago enabled
humankind to settle into more sedentary
agricultural and pastoral rhythms
we did so primarily where the climate
was amenable
the so-called climate niche with much of
the world population clustering between
20 and 30 degrees north latitude
and within those latitudes we planted
roots as close as possible to rivers and
estuaries
environmental factors such as droughts
and floods
political phenomena such as wars and
genocides and technological advancements
such as air conditioning and the
internet
have all played a role in shaping our
human geography the grand story of our
geographic evolution can't be told
through only one
cartographic lens rather we can only
fully appreciate
the chain reactions among
and the misalignments between
these layers of geography by
superimposing them on top of each other
generating an image as messy
and as complex
as it is accurate
and revealing
and what such a layering unveils to us
is the misalignment among the geography
of resources borders
economics and people
resources are abundant where people are
few
and resources are scarce where
populations are dense
billions of people are trapped behind
borders in increasingly uninhabitable
places
while increasingly livable geographies
are actually becoming depopulated
the imbalances among and steering our
system towards a more dynamic
equilibrium should become our common
civilizational mission
it's no longer an overstatement to say
that our fundamental survival depends on
rectifying these misalignments
that's because we can no longer take
global population growth for granted
instead the human population will soon
taper
plateau
and eventually decline
much sooner than we thought it would
today's youth
gen y
gen z
gen alpha
together represent 60 percent of the
human population
but as our children
defer from having children or have fewer
children or none at all
each generational cohort is getting
smaller and smaller
and that means
that the present generation that
dominates the world today is also going
to dominate the future
to put it in sci-fi terms the present is
the future
so now we've established our nomadic
origins
our geographic misalignments and our
demographic plateau
we may reach 9 billion people on a
planet where most people live in
uninhabitable places
so where do we go from here
to say that humanity is at a crossroads
would be something of an understatement
the scenarios that we can conjure up
range from mass extinction
to a harmonious relationship with nature
in move i developed four scenarios for
the future
and for the purposes of this book i
constructed these scenarios along the
axes of sustainability and migration
we'll start with the two low
sustainability scenarios
the new middle ages
harkens back to the eurasian world of a
thousand years ago it was a fragmented
world of local survivalism
and limited trade
a world of moats and tactical alliances
to map it on to the present
it suggests a scenario in which
technological innovation to forestall
climate change and technology transfer
to promote sustainability elsewhere are
totally and utterly insufficient
furthermore migration to livable
geographies is strictly limited
the other low sustainability scenario is
called barbarians at the gate
the romans use this expression in a very
literal sense as they fortify their
settlements in the early centuries a.d
before their
collapse here we also bring in the
geopolitical dimension of water wars and
land grabs
but also mass migrations as refugees
overwhelm borders
it's a similarly chaotic scenario
but a more globalized one due to
international conflict and political or
climate refugee flows
now we have the somewhat more positive
scenarios
regional fortresses is in many ways a
continuation
of the present
it's a world of regional strongholds
like north america europe russia japan
that primarily invest in their own
sustainability and self-sufficiency of
agriculture energy and industry
they reign in supply chains through near
shoring they engage in some degree of
technology transfer to support
developing regions towards similar ends
but they continue to ward off
large-scale migration
even violently if needed
less globalization may make them feel
more secure
but it doesn't make them wealthier given
their aging demographics and their
smaller markets
the fourth and final scenario is called
northern lights
it's the most optimistic
ambitious and progressive scenario
but what would it take to get there
the pathway to northern lights
calls for a resettled human population
mostly around geographies of the
northern hemisphere
but it also suggests a fluid circulation
of people
either seasonally
or to cope with various kinds of
unpredictability
whether political or ecological
in this scenario we also pre-design
our habitats to be more circular
in the usage recycling of water
production of energy through renewable
resources and other means
today
elements of all four of these scenarios
are visible either within certain
regions and of course at the global
scale to a greater or lesser degree
and if constructed properly the future
will in fact embody all of these
scenarios the only question is where and
to what extent